[ __ ] just farted God smells like
[ __ ] Scott Diana so on oh why is
going on YouTube now I was a college
student once and though you may not
believe it I have a case II own mmm
that's right ladies hold your pajamas
twist your nipples I read at a
collegiate level well apparently that's
not that impressive anymore because
everybody does but how do you spell
collegiate us that is co mm wow you shut
the [ __ ] up y'all never tried to piss up
a dumb ass what you do is you take
Captain what he says and ask him to
spell that [ __ ]
watch us bring him up like this I should
do that I told him one dude who called
me a [ __ ] to spell the word and this is
how our conversation went down really
well why don't you spell the word [ __ ]
bi CH [ __ ] you forgot the T dumbass
it's what [ __ ] I don't even like can't
be what I need people ah but while
attending college for a certain amount
of years there are a few things they got
on my nerves so y'all might know what it
is LG up any let's get it let's go
why the [ __ ] are test books so expensive
what do I have to pay thousands of
dollars on [ __ ] that I don't want to
read I'm gonna be honest with you right
now
I barely read [ __ ] that's important okay
well it says right here don't stick your
head in the blender I know that you uh
stuck your hand in a blender didn't you
know talking about $800 for paper and
cardboard [ __ ] body groceries tell me
why after you buy your books you can't
sell it for anywhere near the price that
you got caught it's gotten to the point
where students are starting to turn and
do textbook drug dealers literally y'all
see those students that are out there
slinging textbooks like they're a
[ __ ] crackhead excuse me by my test
I'll suck you at the bumper coffee
how much want some thought pleasure this
is the best advice that I'm gonna give
you buy or rent your books at a
discounted rate why the [ __ ] would you
ever pay for a textbook full price it's
the same [ __ ] same information as
sometimes these pre used books have
highlighted information from people you
know who are lot smarter than you did
you know damn well if you buy textbook
with a friend and that book was brand
new he dumb as [ __ ] I hated being
college bro because he not only was I
broke as hell to begin with college did
not help it was a worse when you were
around rich college kids right because I
personally could not relate to rich kid
problems look at a broke-ass dude an ass
remember what you want to wash your
parents see ya over the summer let me
ask you something
what the [ __ ] in a yacht you know what I
got is two poor people a [ __ ]
boat with joke dumbass added you cuz I
don't know what I got is well let me ask
you something you know what the street
prices for a [ __ ] beat down for a 99
[ __ ] get mad at me cuz I'm gonna
steal ya
how the hell was I supposed to know that
she had a silent C and a silent H maybe
those [ __ ] speak up
everything I remember if I could not
relate to these fools because we did not
have similar life experiences and you
know for me it was hard for me to relate
to people who saw the problems with
money I remember my first year in
college I almost got to fight with his
dude and he looked me and said yeah but
your hands off me and I'll owe
[ __ ] to me for what I'm broke up poor
people don't have a concept of being
sued you can't case something for
somebody who has nothing what you want a
tic-tac and a paper clip from my bank
account and you see this is also the
very reason why you don't ground a
ghetto child you don't have [ __ ] to take
away from it you send into his room he's
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of his dick
cumulative finals I hated that [ __ ] for
those of you out there who don't know
what this is curative finals are exams
that test you on [ __ ] from day one let
me get this straight you want me to tell
you everything that happened in World
War two from the day it started what the
hell oh my god [ __ ] there are
people who survived that [ __ ] and even
they don't remember you know what how
about this how would I test
you on something that happened two
months ago listen you you remember
professor what would that exact lunch
that you had two months ago on February
22nd yeah exactly fam you know why you
don't remember professor because that
[ __ ] happened two months ago and it was
irrelevant it's like all the information
I'm learning from your class that is
irrelevant to my career choice back now
don't get me wrong I love college I love
reading especially because of the life
experiences that you can take from but
don't get mad at me when I can't
remember the [ __ ] Encyclopedia
Britannica
cuz if you do let me tell you some you
know when you can remember you can
remember the ridges on my nutsack that's
Oh what is going on YouTube now I
brought up this topic of college
textbooks so I'm here to help you out
now if you guys are going to college or
you're already in college you I should
know that the college bookstore doesn't
have the best deal for textbooks it's
crazy expensive so this is where I'm
going to save your ass some money that's
right wha scrilla cheddar [ __ ] what's up
greenbacks slug looks calm we'll compare
the prices of all these textbooks so you
can get the cheapest price online yes
cheap it so this is how you're going to
do it you're going to go use slug books
calm now aslam looks calm does it takes
all the prices from the cheapest signs
online for these textbooks to save you
the most money now I'm going to explain
how slug books work so listen up first
find the ISBN number of the books you
need at your college your professor or
your books or on their website and
search for it on slug books so what that
number does with slug books calm it
takes that information and it compares
the prices of that book with tons of
websites now if you go to the slug
ebooks comm link in the description box
below yes it will save you money so
please give it a try and huh
check it out you will see a cartoon
version of me on that website yeah
that's right so if you see these
cartoons and you watch my videos you
just might recognize a few of these
characters that they do you know they
listen for any of you out there who have
not used love books before you know that
there are textbooks out there that can
go up to about 400 to 500 dollars so yes
if you search for an online with this
you can even find it for maybe 10 bucks
yeah don't be an idiot and just save
money so yeah
is a date though stance of approval so
please check that out and I will see you
guys next Sunday
next Sunday yeah or the Sunday yeah but
what what can I say I wanna thing when
they get the money budmo glad of it
can't just give me a tool and they're
not going home and you see this is mmm
I'm sweating no honey child you ain't
gonna sweat today you ain't gonna fly to
Dayton